merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre ce week-end à 15 km
de ma circonscription à Sainte Soline
une petite minorité radicale avec en son
sein des groupes violents a voulu
empêcher par la force la construction
d'une réserve de substitution dans les
Deux-Sèvres le résultat nous le
connaissons 60 gendarmes blessés dont
une vingtaine dans un état grave des
champs ravagés des appels à la
désobéissance civile d'élus de la
République c'est tout simplement
inacceptable je veux exprimer tout mon
soutien aux forces de l'ordre mobilisés
sur le terrain
vous faites quoi là
je veux exprimer tout mon soutien aux
forces de l'ordre mobilisés sur le
terrain mais surtout aux agriculteurs
ils se sentent assiégés diabolisé ont
peur pour leur outil de travail dans
lesquels ils ont investi et sur lesquels
reposent la viabilité de leur ferme
ainsi qu'aux habitants des alentours qui
ne comprennent absolument pas se
déferlement de violence mais qui veut la
guerre de l’eau dans la Vienne ce soir
nous allons signer un protocole de l'eau
le protocole du bassin du Clain que vous
connaissez bien madame la Première
ministre fruit de trois ans de
concertation de 10 ans de réflexion avec
de larges soutiens des acteurs de l'eau
une démarche certes complexe mais
exemplaire en faveur de l'autonomie
alimentaire et du traitement de
l'urgence écologique l'eau et
l'alimentation sont les enjeux du siècle
nous avons donc l'immense responsabilité
de construire ensemble le consensus de
l'eau celui qui protège la ressource la
biodiversité dans nos sols et nos
rivières mais qui apportent aussi des
solutions pragmatiques à son partage
dans le contexte de sécheresse que nous
connaissons madame la Première ministre
je le rappelle il n'y a pas de vie sans
eau pas d'agriculture sans eau pas de
biodiversité préservée sans eau pas de
pêche sans eau la liste est infinie ma
question est simple que de vous faire
pour empêcher qu'un petit nombre qui a
fait la preuve de sa violence et de son
mépris des règles démocratiques
remettent en cause la mise en œuvre des
solutions concrètes pour une
alimentation de